[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make way for uh reggie miller nba
hall of famer he did uh pelican sons
last night and on the call for game six
in new orleans that'll be tomorrow night
7 30 eastern on tnt reg good to have you
back is there any chance that zion could
play tomorrow night
no okay
look i've been calling and clamoring for
it
but uh you see him in warm-ups and
he looks over oh he looks overweight
but some of the moves he is making in
his warm-ups oh my goodness and that's
why i keep yelling to the rooftops
if you can go through your legs two
times
and reverse 360 jam
you can give me 15 minutes theodore you
can give me 15 minutes but i think the
pelicans are gonna air on the side of
caution
and they are in such a rhythm right now
with
the nucleus that has gotten them to this
point
i don't think they want to kind of mess
up the apple cart
do you think he wants to play and they
don't want him to play
i think if i'm sitting over there and
i'm zion williamson and i feel i could
help this team
sure i'm
any player wants to feel that they can
be out there to you know help their
squad out
um this feels like the opposite of the
nets with ben simmons
that i don't know i i look it's hard for
me
you know people always ask me now you
know i've been retired 15 plus years
do i miss the game and i tell usually i
tell them during the regular season not
so much because of the travel and the
day-to-day wear to tear
what i miss the most about nba is now
the playoffs
and to see some of our young stars not
want to be
a part of it and now again i know
injuries are a part of it and i'm not
saying zion does not want to be a part
of it
but this is the best time of the year
because
you're going against
the best and it's the adjustments in the
everyday stress of what i missed about
the playoffs
the adjustments and just hand-to-hand
head-to-head
mental challenge battle
and i'm sure if zion could play
it was allowed to play
he would be out there but just looking
at his body he doesn't look like he's
100 in shape
and when you get to this level of the
playoffs you've got to be all in
well you did say this about ben simmons
out for game four this dude has zero
competitive fire
um he did say that he wasn't gonna play
in game three there was a chance he was
going to play in game four
i i just don't know what it is if if it
is
you know that there's something deeper
to this
um
yeah i i don't know i'm trying to figure
it out i'm trying to be sensitive to it
but after a while you're like look if
you think you can play then this isn't
mental this is about physical and what
treatment are you getting you know it
just feels like it's fair game to be
able to ask him some of these things
because he keeps hinting and and
somebody's leaking this information to
the media saying hey you know what he's
been pain-free for 10 days been working
out he could play and get like
i i i'm baffled at what happened this
entire year with ben simmons
the nets easily could have won game one
you usually could have won game two they
come back home down love to
and
as a former basketball player
and
during my time you know i had i wouldn't
say bad ankles but i would twist my
ankles from time to time and being able
to play through that pain
case in point against mj during the
conference finals
at some point
and you know for him to say i'm not
gonna play game three but i could play
game four if you could play game four
you could play game three
when your team needs you the most so you
let that slide
then when you go down 3-0
you can't come back and say my back is
hurting i had a misstep
the optics of it just looks bad
you can't hint of coming back
and then all of a sudden be put back on
the shelf
that was the whole point i was making
because you've as
they need you
and as slim as of a chance as it was
they were never going to come back and
win that series but you still do have
kevin durant and a kyrie
and if you win one game you don't know
someone could twist the ankle in boston
and they'd be down one guy
it it's possible
not likely but it was possible but go
out there for 15 18 minutes you know
give your fan base something to look
forward to for next season
but to totally shelf it
and that's what you've done all season
long
i think that's what frustrates people so
that's why i say
the comparative fight you've got to have
you you have to have it and a number
number two
your team has got to feel like they can
trust you
do you think he plays for the net do you
think he wants to play
like next year what happens in the
offseason where all of a sudden
he's ready to go and
he's a different player
i guess we'll see next october now won't
we yeah i mean it
he won't play in the summer league they
won't risk that
so we'll we'll just have to wait till
next october that's great but if you're
the nets don't you have to wait and and
see what this looks like with kevin
durant and kyrie and ben simmons
i mean you made the trade if not you
basically gave
james harden away which at this point i
mean james is not looking great but at
least he's playing
and he's capable man i would have him
play in this summer league reg like at
some point
i gotta have him out
no way they're gonna risk him playing in
the summer league because if he plays in
the summer league against g-league and
rookies and he gets shown up
that fan base will go crazy
they can't risk him looking bad
or
or not looking up to par after having
all this time off
they are not going to risk him playing
in a summerly game
talking to reggie miller he'll be on the
call game six tomorrow night 7 30
eastern on tnt the pelicans and the sons
booker is not going to be back for this
series
no okay he's done
and he very well could be done
the start if they were to advance the
start of the next round i mean these
things take two to three weeks
and we're coming up on game six tomorrow
um well luca luca was out for a while
as well with the camera
and a capturing two different things
okay different things um
but again you never know and like
you we talk about competitive fire
devin booker has it i think if it was up
to devon booker he probably would would
risk it
but he was out two and a half three
weeks on the right one i believe he had
in december or january
i think this one is the left one so
i think they're going to err on the side
of caution you don't win 32 games
on the road
32 games at home 64 wins without having
some hiccups
both chris paul and devin booker at
times have missed a chunk of time and
they didn't miss a beat
so i think that's what they're counting
on their experience their finals
experience from a year ago
and they are a deep team and there are a
bunch of role players that understand
that
you just hope they're not taxing chris
paul because last night going into
halftime
he was absolutely gassed and they're
putting a lot on his plate and that's
why other guys like
mikael bridges who played great
playoff career-high 31 points
those kind of guys have to step up and
and play a significant role
john morant last night
the grizzlies come back from 13 down and
he had a dunk heard around the nba uh
you know recency bias well that's got to
be the greatest playoff dunk of all time
um it's not it was impressive because it
helped that team win a game that's the
most important thing out of this um
you got a few
all-time playoff dunks that uh you want
to bring up
i would say
was the dr j cuff over michael cooper
was that a playoff game or was that a
regular season game i think that was uh
playoffs
that would have been finals
that's one of them i'm trying to think
another all-time dunk in a game i'm sure
michael has a few
uh scotty over ewing oh yes scotty
definitely over ewing then throwing them
down walking over them walking over to
spike lee telling him to sit his
yeah that's classic that whole
i kind of like that one that's a good
one john starks dunking on the bulls in
the playoffs the left-handed yes
left-handed
kj dunking on elijahuan
left-handed
very nice yeah but but here's the other
thing reg it's if when you dunk on
somebody
there's somebody up there to greet you
at the rim
not i'm going to stand here and take a
charge that's not dunking on somebody
but
it is because if you look at where jaw
took off all right the dotted line all
right
all right
and cocked it all the way back but the
guy he had normally nobody was guarding
him up there it was just he had to he
had to maneuver around malik beasley
that is something for you
and i are talking you and i are talking
because we're experienced three-point
shooters we don't get to navigate way up
there
you and i well you don't
that's what you used to at dayton that's
why i still have i i have a knee
replacement reg
what paulie dan we're forgetting a dunk
uh reggie miller versus the nets kenyon
martin jason kidd i think it was an
overtime
and for the record paulie i do have to
say this that was my last official
in-game dunk ever so that was the last
time i ever dunked in a game which i
wish i would have saved it for that
detroit series when taishan was coming
from behind i had nothing left in the
tank
i had nothing left in the tank
damn
i know you still think about that don't
you
yeah because it was a goal 10. okay all
right okay
you can't go there because they didn't
call it
um yes i do think about it
what advice would you give okay let me
let me preface this by saying you know i
see john moran at age 22 attacking the
rim
and we've seen players
young players attacking the rim and then
they eventually
you know develop other skills you either
get hurt or you change or you get hurt
in chain you know jordan stopped going
to the hoop uh iverson started stopped
attacking and derrick rose stopped
attacking
what advice would you give john morant a
22 year old john morant right now
with his game i'm not going to tell him
to stop at all i love his aggressiveness
i think you wouldn't worry about him
getting hurt
he'll over time he will figure it out i
think i guess we could throw dwayne wade
in there as well yeah you don't want to
take away a player's
ability to think and
and to react on the fly
look all the the
the guys that you just mentioned hall of
famers
they figured it out in time now he
missed what like 25 games this year
um
and i i think the way he
approaches the game i'm not going to put
a saddle on a dude where
his biggest attribute is being able to
break down the defense
now learning how to fall knowing how to
roll that will come in time but i'm not
gonna say like dude you need to start
working on your jump shot because you're
taking too many hits no because what
he's doing he gets the grizzlies in the
bonus early he puts pressure on bigs he
gets guys in foul trouble
i am not going to try to put a saddle on
a wild horse i'll try to tame him the
older he gets but you be you jaw and
continue to be great
can you help me understand what bus
rider and bus driver and what the hell
charles barkley and kevin durant are
arguing about ear reg
oh my god
i think it changes every day
truthfully
do you consider
is kevin durant a bus driver or a bus
rider
well here's the thing because
it depends on what wait wait wait you
didn't answer that is he a bus
was he riding the bus or driving the bus
with the warriors
well he was a he was a final mvp
back to back years okay okay
so to me that's somewhat driving the bus
okay where he could have been a writer
is you join to 73 and 19
to get those two rings yeah
that's the that's what people on both
sides of the fence will say if you're
kevin durant fan and if you're not
but
i mean you don't get back-to-back finals
mvp and average 35 points against lebron
james if you're not a bus driver
yeah i i thought charles you know
charles was a bus rider he i mean he
tried to join houston with you know
those stars there
and he got out of uh philly to go to
phoenix
so i i mean there's part of that that if
you want to get real particular he tried
to bus ride to get a title in houston
um but i think all those guys when he
was in houston were pastor prime clyde
hakeem and charles and scotty i mean
these guys were just trying to get
together for one last
hurrah see you're a bus driver you you
never got on somebody else's bus you
were always driving the bus in indiana
for nearly two decades
but maybe i should have been a bus rider
because that's what all
it's funny because we knock kevin durant
for being a bus rider bus driver yeah
but the media says the championships
championship matters championship
championships reggie didn't win a
championship
but
so you know you're knocking from being a
writer versus a driver
at the end of the day media which one is
more important important loyalty
or championships or both well give me
the team you almost went to was it
boston you were going to come back and
play for that team that won the title
yeah but that wasn't given they weren't
considered the favorites but it was
close but you would have won a title
yeah in hindsight but going into that
season did everyone be like oh they're
going to win
it wasn't set that they were going to
win a championship but if you knew
that they were going to win a
championship
would you have come back and played
i i i couldn't do it
because
all the tears i shed in indiana with the
with that fan base
we cried together on all those you know
those hurtful knicks losses bulls losses
lakers losses in the finals
it wouldn't be
fair for me to be
on a podium or a stage pop and bub
because i won my one championship and in
indiana we as a team they we grew up
together
we had the heartaches together
i can't be sipping champagne and getting
a ring and i didn't do it for y'all
that's just my mentality this is my
thinking all right that's fair and i'm
not saying it's right because you know
people on twitter will go crazy
that i didn't win a championship okay
i'm cool with that but at least i i went
down swinging and fighting would you
join me would you join another radio
show
if you could have a better chance to win
don't you think colin coward has been
calling left and right for me to join
his show you think uh you think uh
skip bayless
no skip cycle don't always call me to
come on no absolutely you think i'm
going to jump ship okay to go on one of
those shows when i'm on the premiere
show of all time i don't think so yeah
yeah but you know what we haven't won
anything reg
we're the pacers
we're the indiana pacers of uh sports
talk radio
but we're coming we're coming for you
pti
wilbon yeah
we're coming for y'all yeah those punks
uh reg will be on the call tomorrow
night 7 30 eastern on tnt the pelicans
and the suns thank you red safe travels
love you theodore and i love
my dance take a break back after this